hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to discuss the density
operator for pure states in another one
of our videos on rigorous quantum
mechanics
in the videos looking at the postulate
of quantum mechanics we have
characterized quantum systems
using state vectors called kets today i
want to introduce an alternative
but completely equivalent way of doing
quantum mechanics
the density operator the density
operator will make your life much easier
when dealing with advanced topics such
as quantum statistical mechanics
so without further ado let's go
as an introduction to the density
operator today i will only consider pure
states
so let me start with a reminder on what
the distinction between pure
and mixed states is as always you can
find further details in the videos
linked in the description
simply put a pure state describes a
quantum system whose state is perfectly
known
for example in the videos on the
postulate of quantum mechanics we have
been working with pure states
although in that case we haven't used
this language because there was no need
there for the distinction
it is important to understand that in
quantum mechanics full knowledge of a
state has a probabilistic dimension
for example imagine we have an
observable a with its eigenvalue
equation given by this
in this equation the u i or the
eigenstate and the lambda i are the
eigenvalues
we can always write the pure state psi
of the system in the bases spanned by
the u eigenstates like this
and the expansion coefficients c are
given by the bracket between u and psi
and are called the representation of psi
in the u basis
from postulate 4 of quantum mechanics we
know that when we measure property
a then the probability of obtaining
eigenvalue lambda i
as the outcome of the measurement is
given by the absolute value of ci
squared where for simplicity i'm
assuming a non-degenerate eigenvalue
so in this sense quantum mechanics is a
probabilistic theory
however a state like psi is a pure state
because this is all we can know about
the quantum state
quantum mechanics tells us precisely how
to determine the coefficient c
at any given time how to then calculate
their time evolution using the
schrodinger equation
and the exact probability of obtaining
any given outcome of a measurement as
shown here
now let's remember what mixed states are
mixed state is used to describe a system
for which we only have
incomplete information about the state
this is a feature that also exists in
the classical world and is unrelated to
the probabilistic nature of pure states
in quantum mechanics
for example when we have a macroscopic
system with a number of particles of the
order
of avogadro's number it is impossible to
fully characterize the system be it
classically
or quantum mechanically what we do in
this case
is to use probability in the context of
a statistical mechanics
for example a system at thermodynamic
equilibrium at temperature t
has a probability of being in a state of
energy e proportional
to the exponential of minus z over kbt
where remember
kb is boltzmann's constant a mixed state
in quantum mechanics is a state for
which we only have partial information
in this sense
for example the state could be psi 1
with probability p1
psi 2 with probability p2 and so on
and of course we must have that the sum
over the different probabilities must
add to 1.
each of these psi psi1 psi2 and so on
are pure states
so each has a quantum mechanical
probability associated with it as
described up here
but the point of mixed state is that we
don't know in which of this pure state
our system is
this is precisely where the p
probabilities come in these p
probabilities are independent of quantum
mechanics the same happens in classical
systems where we only have partial
information
today i will introduce the density
operator in the context of pure states
only
we will see that in this case it leads
to an equivalent formalism to that of
state vectors
however to see the full power of the
density operator you should check out
the video on how to use it for mixed
states
to introduce the density operator let's
consider a basis u of our state space
and we choose it to be orthonormal we
can write the general state vector as a
ket psi
and expand it in the u basis as sum over
i c i
u i for a pure state surges psi
here we define the density operator rho
as the outer product
of psi with itself i want to emphasize
that this definition is only valid for
pure states
at this point if you have seen the video
projection operator you will immediately
recognize this operator row
as the projector onto the state psi and
indeed for pure states these two
operators are the same
just like we wrote the state psi above
in the u basis we now want to write the
density operator row
in the u basis remember that to write an
operator in a particular basis we have
to calculate its matrix elements
rho i j they are equal to u i rho
u j plugging in the definition of rho we
get u
i psi psi u j and then this term is
simply the coefficient of
psi written in the u basis c i and this
term is the complex conjugate of the cj
coefficient
so that we get c i c j star
you will notice that the state vector
psi here and the density operator here
contain the same information this
becomes particularly clear when these
two objects are written in the u basis
as we can see that the state vector is
essentially represented by this
expansion coefficient ci
and so is a density operator we know
that the matrix formulation of quantum
mechanics is a very useful way of doing
quantum mechanics
and in that formulation we write the
state vector as usual as a column vector
of ci coefficients the density operator
is of course an operator
so in the matrix formulation it is
written down as a matrix of c i c j star
coefficients
what i want to show in the rest of this
video is that we can do quantum
mechanics in terms of state vectors
like i do for example in the videos on
the postulate of quantum mechanics
but we can also do quantum mechanics in
a completely analogous manner in terms
of the density operator
for pure states using state vectors is
usually the simpler option
so you may think that we're just making
our lives harder by introducing the
density operator
however for mixed states the simpler
formalism is the one in terms of the
density operator so for this reason it
is important to become familiar with
both
let's look at some properties of the
density operator the first
is that it is hermitian row dagger
equals rho
this is very easy to see as rho dagger
equals psi psi dagger
remember that the adjoint of an outer
product simply exchanges the order of
the terms which in this case simply
gives
type psi again and this is rho
the second property is that the density
operator is either potent
which means rho squared equals rho again
this is trivial to c
as rho squared equals the outer product
of psi
multiplied with itself this bracket in
the middle gives one
so we get the outer product which equals
rho
this property which we'll remember is
the defining property of a projection
operator
is true for a pure state because the
density operator is simply projection
operator in this case
however this is no longer true for a
mixed state and consequently this
property is not obeyed by mixed states
a third interesting property of the
density operator is that there is no
global phase ambiguity
consider state psi the corresponding
density operator rho
equals the outer product of psi with
itself
now consider another state psi prime
which equals e to the i theta
times psi we know that multiplying a
state vector by a global phase like this
doesn't affect any physical predictions
so we always have this phase ambiguity
when working with state vectors where we
need to make a face choice
if we construct the corresponding
density matrix rho prime
we get e to the i theta times the outer
product of psi with
psi times e to the minus i theta
the two exponentials combine to give one
so we get the outer product of
psi psi and this means that rho prime
equals rho
so there is no global phase ambiguity
when working in terms of the density
operator
what i want to do in the rest of the
video is to look at how we can calculate
the usual quantities we work with in
quantum mechanics in terms of the
density operator rather than in terms of
the state vector
let's start with normalization for state
vectors
normalization says that the bracket of
psi with psi equals 1.
we write in the bracket in the u
representation this becomes sum over i
c i star and the bra ui multiplying some
over j
cj and the cat uj we can move the sums
to the beginning
and we obtain the double sum over i j of
c i star
c j and the bracket between u i and u j
as the u basis is orthonormal we get
delta i j here
which reduces the double sum to a single
sum over i of the absolute value of c i
squared
now how can we ensure that the density
operator corresponds to normalized state
first using this result up here for the
matrix element of the density operator
note that the diagonal elements of the
density matrix row i are equal to the
absolute value of ci squared
for starters this shows that diagonal
entries of the density matrix
written in the u basis tell us the
probability of measuring the system to
be in the corresponding ui state
but going to the normalization condition
we have from above that 1
equals the sum over i of c i squared
given this relation we can rewrite it as
sum over i of rho i
i remembering that the sum of the
diagonal elements of a matrix is its
trace
then we can rewrite these as the trace
over the density operator rho
so what does this mean we can write the
normalization condition in terms of
state vectors as the bracket of the
state vector with itself
or in terms of the trace of the density
operator
these two expressions are equivalent
the next thing i want to consider are
physical properties and remember that in
quantum mechanics they are represented
by operators
a quantum system is fully specified by
the expectation values of a complete set
of commuting observables
so what we want to show is that we can
build the expectation value of an
observable
in terms of the density operator let's
start with a reminder about how we
calculate the expectation value of an
observable a
in terms of state vectors we calculate
it as brap psi
operator a cat psi to convert this to
the u basis
we first insert two identity operators
like this
then we insert the resolution of the
identity in the u basis as usual
and we can then rearrange the expression
moving the sums to the beginning and
ending up with these three terms
the first is ci star the second is the
matrix element of the operator a
in the u basis and the third is cj
putting this together and reordering the
terms for convenience
we get sum over ij of ci star cj
aij to see how we can rewrite this in
terms of the density operator
let's write again the expectation value
of a as equal to this expression we got
here
so we have this
each of these three terms is a scalar so
we can move the u j psi
term to the front and we get this
remembering the definition of the
density operator
we see that the outer product of psi
with itself here is equal to rho
so we can rewrite this expression in
terms of the density operator like this
we can then move the sum over i to this
point here because u j and rho
don't explicitly depend on i and we get
sum over j
u j rho and the sum over i of the outer
products of u
i u i and then a u j
this sum here is simply the resolution
of the identity so we can rewrite the
whole expression
as sum over j u j the operator product
of rho with
a u j this quantity here is now simply
the matrix element of the operator
product of row with a
so this is again the sum of the diagonal
entries of the matrix rho
a and we can rewrite this as a trace
over row a
so what does this mean we can write the
expectation value of an observable
a in terms of state vectors as the
bracket between the state vector
with a acting on the state vector or
in terms of the trace of the product of
the density operator
with the operator a these two
expressions are equivalent
as a quick aside how can we determine
the probability of a measurement
outcome for a physical property in terms
of the density operator
remember from the video on measurements
that to do this we need to consider the
eigenvalue equation of the operator a
acting on eigenstate a and i giving
eigenvalue a
n and eigenstate a n i or as usual the i
runs from 1 to g n and labels the
degeneracies of eigenvalue a n
the only possible outcomes of a
measurement of observable a
are one of its eigenvalues a n and the
probability of measuring eigenvalue a n
if we have a state psi can be written as
the expectation value of the projection
operator p
n with respect to state psi where the
projection operator projects onto the gn
dimensional subspace
spanned by the eigenstate of the
eigenvalue a n
this is simply an expectation value so
we can use the result we just derived up
here
to rewrite this probability as the trace
of the product of the density operator
row
with the projection operator pn so this
is how we predict the probability of the
outcome of a measurement
using the density operator
we now know how to characterize the
properties of a quantum state in terms
of the density operator
all that is left to do is the time
evolution of the quantum state
remember that the time evolution in
terms of state vectors is governed by
the schrodinger equation
i h-bar derivative with respect to time
of psi
t all equal to the hamiltonian acting on
psi
t to understand the time evolution
in terms of the density operator first
consider the time derivative of rho
this is equal to the time derivative of
the outer product of psi
t with itself by the definition of the
density operator
using the chain rule we find that this
gives two terms
the derivative of the first times the
second plus the first term times the
derivative of the second
this derivative is the one that appears
in the schrodinger equation so we can
write it
as equal to one over i h bar multiplying
the hamiltonian
acting on the state psi by contrast
this term is the derivative of the bra
so we need to rewrite this expression in
the joule space like this
remember that to go to the joule space
we need the complex conjugate
hence the minus sign here in general we
also get the adjoint of the operator
here
but in this case we can use the original
hamiltonian because it is a hermitian
operator
we're now ready to evaluate the time
derivative of the density operator
inserting the expression for the
derivative of the ket into this term
here
we get this and inserting the expression
of the derivative of the brain to this
term here
we get the second term these two outer
products are simply the density operator
so we can rewrite this expression as one
over i h bar
h rho minus rho h
finally this is equal to one over i h
bar and the commutator of the
hamiltonian with rho
so what does this mean we can write the
time evolution of a quantum system in
terms of the time evolution of state
vectors
as given by the joiner equation
or in terms of the time evolution of the
density operator as given by this
equation
these two expressions are equivalent
overall we have seen that we can do
quantum mechanics for pure states
in two equivalent ways the first is in
terms of state vectors
as shown by the expressions in the first
column and the second
is in terms of the density operator as
shown by the expressions in the second
column
the density operator provides an
equivalent language to quantum mechanics
to that of the state vector
so what is the point of introducing an
alternative way of doing quantum
mechanics
as an introduction today we only covered
pure states for which state vectors and
the density operator are largely
equivalent
to really appreciate the power of the
density operator
what you should do next is to check the
videos where we use it to study
mixed states those from the basis of
quantum statistical mechanics that
allows us to study macroscopic systems
using quantum physics if you liked the
video or would like to send me
suggestions for future videos
please subscribe